what I want to introduce you to in this
video is the idea of a Keynesian
Keynesian cross so this is one of the
tools of analysis of Keynesian thinking
which is really the idea that maybe
every now and then the GDP when it's at
equilibrium isn't at an optimal state
it's well it's operating well below
potential and the way that we might be
able to get if you are a follower of
Keynesian thinking the way that we can
get it closer to potential closer to
full employment is by somehow affecting
aggregate demand in some way and what
we'll see is we're going to build up our
Keynesian cross analysis based on what
we understand from the consumption
function so we're going to first start
thinking about planned expenditures
we're going to think about what happens
when planned expenditures deviates from
actual output from actual expenditures
so right over here so this is very
similar what we've done before we're
actually thinking of it in terms of
planning so let's say we have planned
expenditures expenditures planned and we
just we could just write the the
components of aggregate expenditure here
well you're going to have consumer
spending you're going to have investment
and I'm going to be careful here I'm
going to call it planned investment this
is exactly what firms are looking to
produce and the reason why I
differentiate this year is because if
for whatever reason aggregate
expenditure is less than they expect
then they might build up inventories and
those inventories get counted as
investment so those would be excess
inventories above and beyond planned
inventories if actual demand is higher
than expected then it might eat into
inventories and when inventories are
eaten into it actually takes away from
planned investment so there would
actually be kind of a you'd be eating
into the total investment in that
situation so that's why I'm going to
differentiate between planned investment
and actual investment and then of course
you have government spending and then
finally you have net exports and for the
sake of the analysis of the Keynesian
cross and once again this is a super
oversimplification we're going to assume
that any at any given level of GDP or
aggregate output that these are all
constant that these are not really
dependent on aggregate output or GDP
which is of course a huge
oversimplification so if we were to plot
any of these vs. if we were to plot any
of these
versus aggregate income we'd say that
they are really a flat line so maybe
planned investment might look like
something like something like that maybe
government spending would look something
like that in no ways at some level
that's pre-planned it's it's kind of
exogenous to our model it's not
dependent in any way it's an external
factor assuming it's fixed it's not
dependent on aggregate income and so
government spending it would look
something like that and that exports
maybe it looks something like that the
one of these the factor that you can
imagine because I said we're going to
build on top of the consumption function
that is that we're going to assume is
driven by aggregate income is
consumption right over here and so the
way that this thing will look the way
that this thing will look is you have so
let me draw another another plot right
over here draw another plot we have
aggregate income that is going to be our
independent variable and then over here
we can just view this as expenditure X
spend ature so if we were to just plot
if we were just to plot consumer
spending we've seen that before
especially if we assume a linear
consumption function so what we studied
in the last few videos these were all
linear consumption functions and
depending on how you write it but they
all look something like this they have a
positive vertical axis intercept and
they have an upward slope that is less
than one so consumption by itself would
look something like this this would be
consumer spending as a function of as a
function of aggregate income and then if
you add all of these constants to it
then your then your then your your graph
for aggregate planned expenditures would
look something like this so if you added
just net exports would get a little bit
higher because these are constant at any
point you would add this much if you add
government a little higher than that and
if you add all of them including plan
investments you might get something that
looks and I'll do it in this color right
over here you might get something that
looks like something that looks like
this so I'm just starting off with
consumer spending I'm fine I'm using a
linear consumption function you don't
have to but it makes the Keynesian cross
analysis a lot more cross like and
easier to analyze and then if you add
all of what we assume to be
things and aggregate expenditures goes
is going to be up here so this right
over here is aggregate planned
expenditures I should say now we know we
know from the circular flow in the
economy that we're not that when an
economy is at equilibrium your aggregate
output is equal to your aggregate
expenditures or your aggregate
expenditures is equal to your aggregate
income so really an equilibrium these
two things are going to be equal and we
can actually plot a line that shows all
the points that those are equal that
would be a line that has essentially a
slope of one where Y is always equal to
expenditures so it might look it might
look something something like this and
this is where the name Keynesian cross
comes from because essentially you have
planned expenditures and then right over
here you have the equilibrium line or
what I call the equilibrium line because
these are all points where income is
equal to expenditure right over here
income is equal to expenditure income is
equal to expenditure so when you look at
aggregate planned expenditures or you
could even view this as kind of
aggregate demand as a function of
aggregate income this is the actual
point where the Inc where the actual
economy is at equilibrium where
expenditures are actually equal to where
expenditures are actually equal to
output and actually it's a little bit
skewed the way I drew it but these
actually should be this should be like a
square actually let me see if I can draw
it a little bit a little bit clearer
than that just so it'll actually looks
like a 45-degree line so maybe it looks
it should really be a 45-degree line
like that and so that seems a little bit
better so that's the point at which we
are at equilibrium and actually I don't
like that because it makes it a little
bit harder to analyze and hopefully you
get the idea this should be a line
that's where expenditures is equal to
aggregate income so I'll do it like this
just so it intersects at a point that's
a little bit easier for me to analyze
now this is where Keynes II the cranes
Keynesian cross becomes a kind of
interesting tool because we can start to
think about what happens in situations
so this is this is an equilibrium this
is an equilibrium level of GDP what
happens if for whatever reason that
aggregate output aggregate income is
then that equilibrium level so let's
think about that scenario so let's say
we're over here let me do that in
magenta let's say we're over here let's
call that y1 so what is going on what is
going on right over here at y1 over here
the aggregate output which is the same
thing as aggregate income is right over
here well this is the actual planned
expenditures is right over here
so all of this excess all of this excess
above kind of the planned demand these
are essentially going to be inventories
building up the economy is producing
more than it actually needs inventories
are going to build up firms are not
selling all of their products and that
excess built up inventory is going to be
reflected in investment so in this case
in this case this Delta this Delta is
going to be added to your planned
investment to get what the actual
investment might be and when an when and
when an economy is at that state then
firm time to tell oh my god we're
building inventory more than we expected
we're not selling our products we're
going to lower output so it there's kind
of a natural feedback mechanism for the
GDP to go back to equilibrium and let's
think about what happens if it's below
that equilibrium point let's say that
GDP is let's call that right over here
so this is y2 let me actually write as a
subscript I don't know if there's a
superscript there but we could call this
we could call this y2 so over here over
here aggregate demand at this level of
output is more than what's actually
being output people want more goods and
services so right over here this is kind
of a deficit of output and so this shows
that people will be digging into
inventory that the the existing
inventories or the existing investment
was not enough or I guess another way to
think they'll they'll essentially
inventories will be contracting if I
let's say business was constant I had a
lemonade stand
I just keep an inventory of five cups of
lemonade on hand and I sell a cup every
hour if all of a sudden people start
buying two cups an hour my inventory is
going to start getting depleted and so
this is what's reflected actual output
actual output is below what's demanded
and when firms start seeing that their
inventories get depleted they say oh my
god I don't want to run
out of my goods and services let me
start producing more and we're talking
about inventories we're really talking
about goods so let me produce more and
so output will once again want to
naturally go to that feedback point so
hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense in the next few videos we'll be
using the Keynesian cross to think about
how the kind of the Keynesian line of
reasoning so how if you change one of
these how that might affect the new
equilibrium level of GDP